Thierry is a French dog breeder
specialized in retrievers he prides
himself on breeding healthy puppies dog
breeding in France is controlled by
strict rules puppies cannot be legally
sold on the market before they are at
least two months old
- what is a family
Pascal tirupati Roxanne lean on drastic
guarantees last naughty a gal monastery
Jules
but not everyone in the EU plays by
these rules online adverts and social
media provide new trading channels that
offer variable protection for consumers
many pets are illegally traded across
the EU often by criminal networks with
disastrous consequences for animal
welfare and potential risks for human
health
it's an EU issue because the animals are
often trafficked across the borders so
it's not only about deep puppy farms
within the countries and saturating the
bar the market within the countries but
it's about trade inside of the UN
crossing the borders members are pushing
for common standards for the breeding of
cats and dogs the EU wide identification
and registration and the creation of
national registers of authorized pet
sellers they also want tougher sanctions
against vets who counterfeit pet
passports possible a national issue of
illegal service you could marady pet
buyers across the EU should have the
guarantee that man's best friend is
treated as such and that their pedigree
is the real thing
[Music]